hi there steve kaufman here it's
american thanksgiving day and uh since
i'm in palm springs
uh i will be attending uh for the first
time in my life an american thanksgiving
party but today i'm going to talk about
grammar and and ways of teaching or
learning grammar and i'm gonna compare
exercises and drills and questions to
simply
patterns
um i'm uh nearing the end of my polish
challenge it's the 26th at the end of
november it'll be 90 days
i'll do a little video video interview
if i can with one of my polish tutors
i've been talking to polish tutors on
italki one of them
she said she asked me what problems do
you have with polish and i mentioned a
few including of course
uh verbs of motion which is always an
issue with slavic languages so she
prepared a lesson on verbs of motion
and she had you know exercises and
please complete the questions and so i
was doing this in my discussion with her
if you know make sure you put in the
right verb and all this kind of stuff
and so we did this for an hour
and then after the
session
then of course and i get as usual a list
of of my main errors uh during the
lesson as well as these uh questions
that she had given me
so i import these into links so that i
can review the words and phrases
and i kind of came
my feeling and i'd be interested in
other people's reactions my feeling is
that the exercise by the way i'm sitting
on one of these exercise balls that's
why i'm bouncing up and down i hope that
doesn't disturb you too much
um
the uh hour spent
trying to come up with the right
verb and trying to answer the questions
and complete the sentences
i think didn't help me very much i don't
retain very much i kind of feel that
there is pressure on me to to answer to
complete the sentence to and and a lot
of this pressure
actually is negative insofar as learning
is concerned when i see
um you know a list of sentences with
different verbs of motion or if people
can actually make a little story with
different verbs of motion and i can read
these and listen to them
and save them at link and see them again
then gradually i will get used to them
you can't teach something like this it's
not because we had a lesson and i
answered questions that i've moved along
that much in my opinion in this process
of learning something in fact
it may be that some of the other issues
that came up in our uh discussion my
case endings maybe i picked up on some
of that
rather than what she was deliberately
trying to teach me so i just i just have
this feeling it almost confirms me that
not to mention the fact that i prefer
just to have a conversation and then to
get this list of words and phrases which
i review which is also this very gradual
layering combined with the listening
that i'm doing interesting listening
that i'm doing about history
occasionally reviewing filters simple
stories and there's this just gradual
layering and accumulation and and that
this is pleasant and this is
slowly effective but that's deliberate
testing and answering this question and
completing the sentence is less pleasant
more stressful and probably less
effective when it comes even to learning
the issues of grammar which will
eventually slot in if we are determined
to learn them and and along the way we
occasionally will consult a table or
look up some rules but mostly just
listen and read notice and gradually we
improve so that's my take on grammar
sort of deliberate grammar instruction
versus versus learning grammar through
exposure to to a group of sentences you
know
concentrated examples of a certain
pattern and or then just noticing them
in our listening and reading so i look
forward to your
comments and the next and last uh video
in this whole
polish challenge
series will be an interview with one of
my tutors thank you for listening bye
for now